[Music]
in the sun-dappled streets of a small
town a proud mother showed off her
newborn son upon noticing his lucky
birthmark townsfolk predicted he would
marry a princess but soon these rumors
reached the ears of the wicked King
enraged the King stole the child away
and sent him hurtling down the river but
the infant's luck proved greater than
the Kings plan years later the king was
traveling his realm when he spotted a
strapping young man with an uncanny
birthmark after confirming the child's
origins the sly King entrusted the boy
with a letter for the Queen the youth
eagerly set out to deliver the message
not knowing he was carrying his own
death sentence that night roaming
bandits stumbled upon his camp yet when
they read the brutal letter they were
filled with pity deciding to make
trouble for the king instead they
scribbled a new note as soon as the
youth arrived at the palace he locked
eyes with the princess the two felt
destined for each other and when the
Queen read that the king approved this
union she joyfully organized a whirlwind
wedding when the King returned he was
furious but he couldn't execute his
daughter's beloved without reason so he
devised a diabolical trial he ordered
the youth to travel to Hell itself and
return with three golden hairs freshly
plucked from the devil's head
only upon succeeding could he return to
his bride the youth searched across the
land for the entrance to hell until he
finally reached an eerie village here he
saw some villagers gathered around a
well they closed in on the youth
refusing to let him pass until he
answered their question why was the well
dry the youth replied I will answer when
I return they directed him further into
town where he came across another set of
villagers contemplating a gnarled tree
they refused to let him pass until he
answered their question why was the tree
barren again the youth responded I will
answer when I return these villagers
guided him to the dock where an elderly
ferryman awaited as he paddled through
the black water the ferryman rasped a
third question how can I escape my
interminable task once more the youth
promised I will answer when I returned
at last they reached a hut sinking into
the swampy banks of Hell reluctantly the
youth knocked on the rotting door the
devil's grandmother answered his call
she was known to help some visiting
Souls and harm others the youth had just
finished his story when they heard the
devil's footsteps without warning the
boys world appeared to shrink the
devil's grandmother lifted him into the
folds of her sleeve and welcomed her
grandson
the old woman set to work lavishing the
devil with food and drink when he fell
asleep she deftly plucked three gleaming
hairs from his head with each plucked
hair the devil briefly awoke and
complained about his dreams full of
nearby villages and their problems the
next morning the youth departed armed
with three golden hairs and three pieces
of information he shared the devil's
first dream with the ferryman if the
boat man could hand his oars to a
willing passenger he would be free from
his task back at the village the youth
declared that there was a mouse
gnawing at the root of the tree and an
enormous toad blocking the well the
villagers rewarded him handsomely for
his health back from his journey the
youth thrust for Devil's hairs of the
king that his greedy father-in-law only
had eyes for the gold the sly youth told
the king that even greater wealth
awaited him across the river immediately
the king hastened to the river bank
eager to claim his riches he held out
his hands impatiently to the grinning
ferryman who happily handed over his
oars for more love fuel journeys to the
underworld follow Orpheus on his quest
to bring back Eurydice or learn more
about the Egyptian Book of the Dead
an ancient guide meant to facilitate
smooth passage to the afterlife
[Music]